how-how-how Matt isolate the sound of my
neck snapping holy [ __ ] hello everybody
my name is markiplier welcome to hot
date now I'm air just broken my neck and
Twain but that's not gonna stop me from
having a spicy saucy date and the dates
going to be with this adorable pup
because this is a speed-dating game and
if that makes sense
then wow you're weird and smarter than
me em hey hey hey nice to meet ya yo
vote
my name's petunia you are um
markiplier markiplier did your mom give
you that name well in fact no I did give
it to myself because I'm bizarre like
that nice to meet you you look lovely oh
no yo yo Oh God are you cool I'm
tragically uncool
well I'm glad we've sorted this out I am
in fact cool all the kids on the
schoolyard say I'm hipping and happening
I don't know I really don't know oh I
thought you would you seem like you
would are you sure you don't
oh no I don't know are you hiding
something from me markiplier ah it's
calling me on my name I don't know are
do wood hello are do would have okay do
you have a happy place and can I see it
yeah I was once given the name shoe who
is husk I'm pretty sure this was a
friendly jest Bance applo anywhere is my
happy place right here with me here
we're here with me oh if you're happy
and in a place then that's that oh my
god
words of wisdom on a speed tape
oh my god I'm falling in love already oh
man what are you afraid of
let's just get deep in here
what are you afraid of I'm not afraid of
anything except boa constrictors
obviously that kind of goes without
saying yeah it seems pretty sensible
what are you afraid of markiplier do I
get to type here umm I don't know what
am i afraid of what am i afraid of
sharks No
the ocean [ __ ] the ocean
aren't we all little afraid of the ocean
I would completely agree the ocean is a
place of death and no one should be
there are you a fan of markiplier no are
you a flan are you fan of little John
are you fan of snow can't get enough of
it yeah I usually keep some in the
freezer for special occasions that's a
little weird I'm not okay would you like
to see my collection of denim jacket
stamps newts our nineties R&B would you
like to see my collection of denim
jacket I'm very weird
no how could you ask me that you're
right
I'm weird why would you think that's
okay we're not at the level of denim in
jacket form yet sunshine oh come on ooh
it'll be a barrel of lols don't be such
a square
don't be such a square man as much as I
love what you're proposing and as much
as I love it whoa no Saved by the Bell
I had a great time let's meet up again
mm-hmm no oh you look very similar to
the dogs
that's just a date with before my name
is your names petunia my name is Margot
who's gonna come up with a flower pun
but they didn't want it I did again it's
yeah all right fine
uh-oh you've got some nerve if I wasn't
a pacifist you'd be entering a world of
pain markiplier well Jesus
is getting bizarre what do you do for
work I know but it is a bit of that a
bit of carpentry
okay Oh Oh what annoys you besides me
I'm annoyed by a great many things the
wind
markiplier oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you man [ __ ]
you
this is [ __ ] I like the other dog I
forget the name of this is [ __ ] I'm
pissed I'm just one love have you always
been that height do you reckon I'm too
tall
I've heard it a lot before go on be
honest I'm a Sasquatch aren't I well
you're uh you're a big in your you're a
bigan you look like a squash little mug
would face you're a bigan thought so
yeah huh yeah you better be lucky
destined for whoa I thought we were
talking about tall not big okay anyway
are you having a nice time
probably not I don't know kid oh I'm a
kid now Am I oh geez just gonna be a
zingy one-liners me are you familiar
with oh the economic if Oh God
forgettable the work of Mary Curie how
about the economic implications of
Bitcoin Oh for a second there I thought
you were cool I really don't care about
big oh she's got him this date is going
much worse than the last one the last
one they didn't even want to get my
number have you ever ran a half marathon
I don't know oh [ __ ] you man
I'm just trying to be hip I'm trying to
be hip have you ever been do happy
heritage I'm allergic to hipsters
what's it happy I don't know what
hackneyed is I'm trying would you like
to hear a joke my life okay do I get to
pick why can't the potato cheese what do
you call an alligator in a vet now [ __ ]
that one what do you call big pile of
kittens
please rid me of the burden of not
knowing I'm a mount a mountain oh I get
it a mountain thank you thank you so
much you should write it down it's good
are you oh Jesus oh come on let's meet
up again yep bye Oh what is that one
work George let's make this quick
my name is beaut beauty Mick [ __ ] you
face oh that is weird condensation
that's cute
maybe he make [ __ ] you please okay oh
you look lovely Thanks you look um oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] where'd you go to school I'm
still at school wait how old are you way
too old 26 yeah me too
how perfect oh my god we're destined for
each other
oh the stars are big on this blessed day
why do you look so bored when you were
saying that do you believe in a thing
called love
damn straight don't you surely you agree
with me yeah I'm feeling it right now
shameful stare stop oppressing you thin
narrow perspective even I'm sorry [ __ ]
off with you are you someone who likes
to complain excessively douchenozzle I'm
more of a feelings bottler oh me too
I prefer just eating my feelings
the cereal and pasta for me I think you
have some problems bro I think so too
well glad we agree I don't have any
problems Oh would you live in space this
is a very important question I did for
11 years was that a dream I don't know I
don't I don't know if you ever travel
back in time never back only forward the
pass holds only things that have already
happened the future
those that have not whoa damn deep for
real brother well alright weird to call
your date brother but I'm okay with that
see what is your ideal starting pokemons
I've always gone for squirtle there are
a lot of questions and the questions
change did you notice that what can you
pick that one that the start
wait no screw you and screw professor oh
that's exactly what I feel screw you and
screw Professor Oak nah it's okay I'm
alright
have some respect I should I apologize
what would you superpower be you lame-o
oh come on what's it's a perfectly valid
question
like it isn't already perfectly clear
it's not I'm a shape-shifting snappily
dust crime crusher with two sidekicks
all the way oh okay you're a weirdo you
having a nice time welder are you fan of
poetry Oh for a second goddammit through
tears don't talk to me about the poetic
written word oh geez are you someone
that likes to go to the park oh good go
[ __ ] off man I'm trying here I had a
great time I guess you gonna [ __ ] you
man
right I'm not doing this again but you
guys can play this game I found it on
heo I can't remember if God has any
money but there's a lot of different
things going on here so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know if you enjoyed this one I had a lot
of fun with it this is a really cool
game so I'll put a link in the
description below so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video